if you are a seahawks fan you can
celebrate well maybe more accurately you
can relax because a day ago chris sims
it was looking a little dicey it was
looking like maybe they aren't going to
get this deal done and maybe the steps
were going to begin to unfold toward
russell wilson no longer being a member
of the team but now
signed sealed and delivered for five
years russell wilson the current year of
his contract plus four new years and
russell wilson becomes the highest paid
player in nfl history we knew he was
going to be the highest paid player if
he signed the contract the question is
what was the contract going to look like
and the answer is it really isn't all
that different than any other contract
that any other quarterback has ever
signed no i mean he just one-upped aaron
rodgers and became the highest paid
player in football and that's all there
was to it i think at the end of the day
that's all he really wanted going back
to the jimmy fallon interview on nbc uh
so much to say here i think the first
thing is russell wilson uh and again i
think this is the first thing that jumps
out to me about it is russell wilson's
uh
ability to be a businessman comes
through in the end once again and i
think we're continuing to see this
education of nfl players who are
learning how to play hardball with
franchises
i think that's the coolest thing about
it russell wilson he drew a concrete lan
uh line uh and said i this is it it's
either sign me today or i'm going
somewhere else and this will be the end
of us forever and i understand that i
bet he felt a little disrespected to a
degree i mean aaron rodgers got a new
contract with two years left on his deal
you know the all-time greats usually
don't have to be in these type of
situations uh very often and russell
wilson's getting close to that
conversation of all time greats i mean
he's been to two super bowls he's won
one he's made a lot of magic happen and
a lot of different games he's carried
this team in moments when hey other the
offense weapons around them haven't
quite lived up to expectations whatever
it may be so awesome for russell wilson
and awesome for the seattle seahawks
certainly
one thing that disappoints me in this
deal is that russell wilson had what i
thought was a prime opportunity to get
the protection that would come from
having a salary cap percentage
guaranteed over time you have a floor
based upon the money that you will make
in hard dollars you have a ceiling based
upon a percentage of the cap that will
be driven by how high the cap goes we've
got a new cba that is coming possibly
before the start of the 2019 season if
it all works out we've got new tv deals
that will be coming there will be the
ever present gambling angle where more
and more states are putting legalized
gambling in place more money and more
revenue potential for the nfl the salary
caps going to keep going up and up and
up it's been going up even without those
factors by the tune of 10 or 11 million
dollars per year which is one of the
reasons why the quarterback market has
gone up so much in less than two years
chris
there's a chance russell wilson is not
going to be happy with this deal in two
or three years and you avoid that by
tying your compensation to a fixed
percentage of the salary cap i thought
wilson could pull it off and now i'm
starting to wonder whether anyone's
going to pull it off yeah it it it's uh
it's going to be interesting to see yeah
i mean yes within a year from now we i'm
pretty sure he will not be the highest
paid player in football anymore i think
that title is only a matter of time
before it goes to number 15 in kansas
city and then yes maybe two or three
years down the road he's not as happy
but at the end of the day whatever he
got 140 million dollars over four years
and whenever you have the title for
richest player uh in the history of the
sport or richest contract in the history
of the sport you know
i just don't want to hear a whole lot of
complaining i really don't but to your
point mike okay i get it i do wonder
when that happens i mean there was a
there was a time at texas matt brown
right he had a contract situation where
he always had to be the top five highest
paid coaches in college football i do
think that that that might have to
happen maybe that happens for patrick
mahomes who's gonna sign a deal at a
very young age and of course this next
contract for patrick mahomes is going to
be completely in the prime of his career
to where maybe he can say okay you have
to keep me in the top five you know as
far as yearly average salary whatever
that may be and then increases that way
but uh yes it's not happening i know
this is your dream that you want to see
this tied in and it really will be cool
i i do admit that but uh obviously the
seahawks weren't ready to do that type
of deal quite yet
i have another thought that just
occurred to me as it relates to valuing
these contracts because we can look at
these deals in two ways new money
average and total value at signing the
new money average for russell wilson is
35 million per year if we look at the
four new years but it doesn't work that
way they don't they don't finish the
current contract and then start the
extension the current contract whatever
is left gets ripped up and it's a new
contract that starts from right now and
that's the more accurate and honest way
to view this so chris the real value
here for russell wilson and i'm going
somewhere with this because i'm actually
gonna i'm gonna throw a curveball at you
that's gonna surprise you
russell wilson's total value at signing
is five years 157 million that is 31.4
million per year with a five-year
commitment and think of all the ways the
market can change over the next five
years from now till 2023
we had a graphic up that showed the top
quarterback deals a minute or two ago if
the control room can put that back up
and it shows the new money average for
the guys who signed extensions wilson
aaron rodgers matt ryan and the last guy
on that screen is a guy that i like to
dump on from time to time based upon his
on-field performance his contract is
three years 84 million that's new money
and old money that's the value of the
deal at the time it was signed
chris you could make the argument that
three years 84 million fully guaranteed
is better than five years 31.4 million
because you get back to the trough after
three years and if i'm russell wilson
i'd take 28 versus 31.4 if i know i'm
going to be right back here again when
the market has possibly gone up by
another 10 or 15 million per year yeah
okay i i you're right i i understand
that that that to that point yes if he
wanted to totally maximize certainly but
he's getting better security the way
he's doing it right now i mean if you
continue to dump on kirk cousins this
next contract he gets is not going to be
three years 84 million dollars so he's
going to lose a lot of the rams
the rams will give him a good deal oh
you think it's going to be the right the
rams will take care of you i think it's
the rams okay yeah i'd like to see that
go down but either way so i i totally
understand what you're saying but i
still think hey this is russell wilson
he's going to have the title belt for
being the highest paid player in
football the highest-paid quarterback
you know the most guaranteed money we've
ever seen so he's got all of those
things and he's the face of a franchise
uh and i think he's content with that i
don't think you know every guy is
looking to go oh gosh i gotta just
absolutely eviscerate the team and
maximize my money to the ultimate you
know i understand there's the business
side of it but i don't think russell
wilson's uh looking to totally do that i
think he got what he wanted and he got
some security from the seattle seahawks
they made it be known that he's their
guy going forward and
i think at the end of the day that's all
he really wanted he wanted to feel
wanted because that's what all-time
great you know again i understand his
demands and some of these things he's
done over the last month or two because
i think he's looked at recent history
and gone man have we gotten to this
point you know when eli manning won
super bowls was he getting towards the
off-season program still waiting for a
contract or were other great
quarterbacks that we talk about peyton
manning tom brady were they going into
lame duck seasons like this and i don't
you know whether you think russell
wilson's the tom brady or peyton
manning's level okay maybe not but
regardless the point's still the same
he's a big time franchise quarterback
who's really on an arc of a hall of fame
career right now and he felt
disrespected that he was going into the
last year of his deal and he's been
kicking butt and he's been playing
quarterback better than anybody in
football and he just wanted to be
compensated fairly and he wanted the
team to show him that he was their guy
and they were going all in on him as the
face of the franchise
eli manning's most recent contract was
signed just before the start of the
final regular season of his and i meant
more of the prime ones like that yeah i
know that yes but sorry
chris yeah peyton manning got franchise
tagged twice by the colts i mean they
let his contract expire
two different times before they signed
him to a new deal with that franchise
tag attached to him at the time so look
the bottom line is wilson drew the line
in the sand and wilson applied a
deadline that he convinced the seahawks
was a real deadline
and
the the
the ultimate final deal
i feel like he could have done more but
ultimately he got what he wanted and
consider this quote from his agent mark
rogers to the seattle times russell
loves this town this team and these fans
and part of the compromise involved his
affection for all things seattle
the idea of playing anywhere else was
not as appealing as playing right here
the place he and his family call home
think about that last sentence chris the
idea of playing anywhere else was not as
appealing as playing right here that
tells me he considered it how do you
come to the conclusion that it's not as
appealing unless you allow yourself to
mentally begin to stroll down that path
yes and think about what it would be
like to play somewhere else and i want
to go all the way back to what colin
coward said when this really took on a
different vibe the idea that his wife
wants out of seattle well she does she
lost because they're staying for five
more years well yeah she lost but come
on she really won at the end of the day
she won i mean but you saw that they
were chuckling before they go into bed
they're laughing all the way to the bank
chris chris you missed my point yeah
that's my point
and maybe i didn't articulate no you did
i understand i think it was all part of
the game it was all part of the poker
face it was all part of the ruse it was
the twisting of the oreo right he didn't
have that same tell yeah he they did a
hell of a job making the seahawks think
they were serious about leaving because
i guarantee you over the weekend the
seahawks thought he wanted to leave yes
well i like that twisting of the oreo i
love rounders when he puts his ear next
to the oreo very good job by infusing
that into the show uh but uh um
listen he was pissed off i don't think
there's any other way around that and of
course i think his mind wandered down to
oh crap i mean are they serious the team
that i took to the super bowl twice the
team that i've had all these magical
playoff moments and end of the season
moments and uh ever since i've been here
we've been a playoff football team and
in the conversation for one of the best
teams in the nba nfc year after year
after year and there's no talks or you
know really anything substantial about a
contract extension you know didn't seem
like there was anything in the works
five six weeks ago or at least it wasn't
going anywhere fast so i'm sure his mind
did wander to go okay man i guess i'm
gonna have to play hardball uh make a
deadline and maybe start considering
teams that i would maybe want to play
for in the future so i'm sure his his
brain went down that wormhole a little
bit uh and i don't blame him for that i
think that's a natural human emotion in
this type of situation
i do believe him and his agent's quote
at the end of the day that he wanted to
be there in seattle and he wants to stay
there in seattle he's built something
special there's only 32 of these
franchises out there and 32 of these
cities are 31 of these cities and he uh
is the king of one of them and that's
that's pretty special and i think he
realizes that
well and from the seahawks perspective
they had a glimpse of what life would be
like without him they recon configured
the roster around him last year making
him the nucleus of that team they had to
have known at some point they were going
to have to pay this guy and
you could say that there's a certain
amount of relief that it's only 31.4
million over the next five years because
they know
the cap is going to go up right and up
and up and they know within a few years
they're going to look at that 31-4 the
same way they looked at 21-9 from the
last time around where at first hey
that's a big commitment but as the money
keeps pouring in year after year after
year you realize you can afford it and
you can have money left over to
otherwise put a competitive team on the
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports